[Applause]
a day of political drama and violence
after iraq's powerful shiite leader
muktara al-sadr announced his withdrawal
from politics
his supporters broke into the
presidential palace in baghdad's
fortified green zone which houses the
prime minister's office
[Music]
many even taking to the palace pool
our demands are to dissolve parliament
and to hold the corrupt to account and
we say my master mukta al-sadr their
pride is under your feet and will
sacrifice for you victory is ours
caretaker prime minister mustafar
al-karmi halted cabinet sessions until
further notice
but iraq's political life was already in
limbo there's been deadlock for almost a
year since muktara al-sada's party won
the largest share of seats in elections
last october
but it wasn't enough to secure a
majority and sarah hasn't been able to
form a government of his choosing he
told his mps to resign in june and his
supporters have been protesting since
july some even briefly occupied
parliament
they want new elections without the
participation of iran-backed groups
[Applause]
this is an iraqi revolution iraq should
be returned to its people
this is not the first time sars
announced his retirement from politics
and many have dismissed it as a bluff to
gain leverage over his rivals
already several protesters have been
killed or wounded and it's feared
sardar's latest move could lead to yet
more instability
alexia brian al-jazeera